merci de venir novembre prochain c'était
bien l'émission tv qui fait
quelque chose de voir mais je le vois
assez normal c'est surtout qu'ils aient
encore l'amour un donc
c'est
vraiment une séparation en très bons
termes et on s'appelle tous les jours
mais c'est une vision de vie
différentes regardez comme il est beau
si l'os x est pour tous les deux et une
vision de vie différentes moi j'ai pour
ceux qui savent j'ai une maladie
incurable donc que j'ai l'urgence de la
vie et lui l'a 20 ans de moins que moi
est la moins d'urgence et il a envie
d'une vie plus casanière
voilà donc on a décidé on pourrait
penser que c'est le contraire incluant
vite sortir mais toi tu as envie de
voile attend vie de
projets gp ouais je j'aime bouger je
suis un peu il perd un peu trop
hyperactif
voilà et puis plutôt que d'arriver
jusqu'à se détester ça s'est passé en
fait eh bien eh ben ils sont ici là tu
restes et donc aux deux ans et demi
ensemble ensemble ouais et il se situe
veut il n'arrivait plus à trouver sa
place dans la vie que je lui proposais
dans cette vie un peu brusque brusque
c'est à dire toi tu veux tu fais quoi là
bas on est par exemple l'hiver dernier
on est parti cinq mois aux antilles pour
aller faire la tournée des collèges des
lycées pour parler d'amour d'homophobie
etc
voilà puis je suis toujours par monts et
par vaux je suis très engagés dans les
associations je suis ambassadeur de la
fondation du refuge tu vois je te plein
plein de choses et lui il avait envie de
quelque chose de plus simple et parce
que c'est un gars super simple est super
et nortel dit quoi vous êtes du coin eh
bien on s'est dit qu'il valait mieux se
quitter en s'aimant encore et laisser
vivre tu sais je pense qu'il ya vraiment
quelque chose d'important dans l'amour
c'est quand on sait que quelqu'un ait
pas bien quelque part il faut savoir le
laisser partir voilà c'est ce que j'ai
fait ok c'est lui qui t'a par l'italie
c'est lui qui a comme engager des coûts
de mathieu suis pas heureux je suis plus
heureux je je je je les chevaux de
course moment que je n'arrive pas à
trouver ma place et j'ai entendu
et donc jeu on a discuté longtemps un
coup lors de ces heurts la décision
vient vous êtes rapidement va essayer de
donner un nom quand tu quand tu sens qu
on a toujours été très honnête l'un
envers l'autre un donc et puis je
connais par coeur donc quand tu sens ça
sort comme ça du fonds de de son coeur
voilà tu laisse partir alors javier
entamé des démarches pour avoir un
enfant oui c'est un projet que tu va
poursuivre ou pas alors je poursuis josé
j'étais en colombie la semaine dernière
d'accord voilà donc que d'ici 15 mois je
serai pas pas d'accord le rsa c'est un
projet qui par contre ne porte t
il ya pas mal de gens qui nous suivent
sur les réseaux essais on est encore
dans une époque très très compliqué
parce que déjà quand on est sortis
l'émission on avait des menaces de mort
mais là tous les jours pendant que je
faisais mais story demain j'espère en
colombie tous les jours j'avais une ou
deux menaces de mort quand tu rentres et
ça le machin on va te coucher
alors d'avoir des enfants enfin
voila mais c'est comment tu as vécu
l'après l'après émission très bien au
début compliqué parce que parce qu'il y
avait toutes ces menaces tout ça mais je
suis finalement très bien parce que ça
nous a permis de tenir moi je suis très
investi dans les associations un stock
homophobie le refuge et cetera
donc ça j'ai trouvé vraiment un sens à
ma vie dans ces associations et et voilà
quoi je trouve que donner du temps à aux
autres c'est c'est top c'est ce que
cette émission m'a permis de 1 vers
alors qui alexandra pas trop de manque
pas de souci mais je lui tout à l'heure
ouais leur téléphone regarde là ce soir
ouais tu l'âme encore bah oui jouer
ouais mais tu penses que c'est ça
reprendra pas non terminée oui je pense
qu'un jeune homme a parlé le l'arrivée
d'un enfant ça a dû lui faire peur vu
son âge peut-être ça oui il ya un ancien
c'est un lien important de
d'adopter un enfant donc je pense que
lui qui à 27 ans est tous un peu plus ça
a dû lui sa peur un léger 20 ans de plus
mais c'est pas grave l'âge alors il ya
plein de téléspectateurs qui sont très
tristes que vous soyez plus ensemble on
a reçu des milliers mais je te jure des
milliers des milliers d'églises et de
messages est ce que vous êtes bien on
peut pas décevoir mes coups pas du tout
passe alors n'y a pas du tout pensé
vraiment quand tu parle d'amour et de
dieu et de séparation tu penses pas du
tout après et essaye de gérer alors on a
sorti un bouquin en même temps alors les
gens pensent que on s'est séparés qui
d'ailleurs en tête des ventes sur amazon
on a un copain
et il pense qu'on s'est séparé en même
temps pour pour la sortie du bouquin ce
qui est complètement
pour on a retardé la sortie du bouquin
parce que effectivement on a fait un
épilogue un peu différent voilà c'est
tout bon on souhaite d'être heureux en
tout cas bah ouais les bons projets
ouais un lacet l'enfant là maintenant
qu'il pense et j'espère que tu
reviendras nous voir et coisy reims sera
là et bravo en tout cas pas ce que tu as
été formidable dans la voiture il a vécu
[Applaudissements]